oh yeah I'll come in and sell a bunch of
tickets and merge because I'm on your
yeah platform oh man I saw Bert
Kreischer right after that what was it
Joe Rogan's give him a huge bump but
then it was that that machine bit yeah
that that yeah crazy viral mm-hmm
like in Russia bit and I was I don't
know him personally but I was in Denver
when he was in Denver and I just went to
go check out his show and he you could
tell he was like he was like having that
like that I think they added like five
shows after the he was do I roll Mondays
and Tuesdays well he was just staying in
town like did the weekend and then was
like doing like he was like well there I
had three more shows tomorrow night I
mean he was just selling out selling out
so he was like this is like amazing
that's what's good to see with people at
his level though it's like someone who
did it the long way like just forgot
[Music]
we have water now Oh jazz you're
drinking your whoo branded water that's
for you
oh yeah Pontus water I love that but got
local georgia mountain blue water for
the hottest podcast hey oh yeah
we made it made at Cheers so that's for
you man cheers buddy thanks dawg oh yeah
hmm
every episode will now begin with a nice
cold drink he knows it oh I know I know
baby I'll go to like open mics and I'll
like sometimes I've gotten introduced as
he's mr. hot breath or like people will
do it in the crowd I'm a hot brethren my
sister's a hot sister and we out know
all the [ __ ] what's up what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] buddies hot breath you've
been down keep it crispy you were
episode two man yeah wore this shirt for
this is the og logo I may for realizing
oh design could matter yes it could so
this was the one I made but this was our
first merch ever and I had to wear it
because you were our second episode ever
yeah that was that was back in the day
ground floor of hot breath and that was
ground floor of Caleb Cynon right I
wasn't [ __ ] I picked you up from the
MARTA station yes yes you did that's
what you really know and the great part
was you were just about to move to LA
like literally I think that week yeah
was that waiting so I'll link the first
episode in the show notes cuz this is
like pre la caleb and then you move
there and then I feel like in a couple
months you're like on Conan and I was
like wait what what I felt the same way
I was like whoa made me feel like like
life wasn't real hmm Billy and do Conan
and I'm like that exact thing happened
I'm like that what are the odds like
yeah that was just absurd to me that uh
that you can just think something and do
it and I'm like could I just do any like
you know and I'm like can I be an
astronaut like I don't want to be but I
was like it was just crazy how quick it
happened how couldn't believe it yeah
how how
that happen well I moved in July and at
the end of the month I did just for
laughs right in the book or saw me it
just for laughs and they booked before
September so it was a two months later
and then I did Conan Oh so two months
later you I didn't realize it was that
fast yeah how'd you do did you know you
were doing Montreal before you moved out
there then I knew in June that I was
going Montreal so I knew it for a few
weeks
okay I don't think it may be a month
where they see you laughing school
festival and it came in second came in
second right and I was like oh now I'm
like mm-hmm there's more about more
about getting seen than winning and you
always want to win and coming in second
is like it's coming in second it sucks
because you get your hopes as high as
they can be and then they're dashed if
you're eliminated first it's like your
hopes are you know they weren't that
high so I keep trying to it's like when
you get to the World Series and lose
it's like don't give me this excited who
won won the Dodgers no do you hear who
won laughing scoff si oh of course I do
I'll think about it till I die
was grant lyin and I know I love grant
well we're friends
oh good but I'd every time I I do think
about it some I mean I'm not mad anymore
time and he also did have a better set
than me like how was it the show he had
the best set on the show he killed like
he destroyed and I was like he deserves
to won it's interesting you said it's
not always about winning it's about
being seen have you found that to be the
case in all your success really yeah
it's uh it is still it's a weird career
but it's still a career every time
someone gets a promotion in some real
industry it's usually because of who
they know or something it's not always
who's the best and people know fear and
a lot of things aren't fair mm-hmm but
uh you know if you have you bomb but
someone who is important likes it that's
better than having a good set as long as
you have a good you could bomb and the
Conan Booker likes your set and then if
you as long as you kill on Conan it's
all good right some crowds are wrong and
it takes like a professional I I like a
Conan Booker to be like I that wasn't
the best audience I know what comedy is
and that was comedy at one time he
messaged me and was like you don't have
to send me a video he's like you can
just use your phone Recorder he's like I
know what you look like
okay thanks is that how you got the
second go-around
cuz you've been on Conan twice now was
the second submission like a phone video
the second one he saw me do it at it was
another festival it was I think
Bridgetown oh and he was like all right
can you see me let's just work record on
your phone and send me that said again I
was like okay and then and then he
called me at like 5:00 in the afternoon
was like you do it in the morning like
tomorrow like 2 p.m. my car picks you up
I was like ok I think someone had
cancelled that day uh-huh we need
someone for tomorrow and I'd already
done it before so he's like now whatever
he won't be that nervous he's already
done it and the sets ready to go so yeah
I had less than 24 hours notice and was
great what was going through her head
like were you kind of panicking or like
what do I didn't have time to panic as
soon as he said can you do it tomorrow I
was like all right and then I messaged a
show that was near my apartment was like
can I I'm doing Conan tomorrow can I run
the set and they're like of course and
then so after I mean I sent the email
they emailed me back I went to the bar
ran it went home went to sleep woke up
and then did it you only ran it once
well I could only run it once I don't
know if you were I would have tried to
cram like 5 sets in that night no I mean
I I wouldn't want to do that like the
night but the first time I did Conan I
didn't run it the night before because
I'd already I knew a week in advance the
first time and I ran it and I was like
ok it went good I don't want to get
tired of these jokes I don't want to get
you know you know I don't want it to
feel monotonous and I was like the night
before I'm gonna do all different jokes
and then tomorrow I'll be excited to do
these I didn't want it to be like you
know it going through the motions
yeah take us through the motions of
getting on Conan because all of us as
comedians will see a Conan center like
Oh awesome they did it they climb
that mountain but all we see is like the
five minutes or whatever it is but what
is all like the behind the scenes that
we may not see well conan doesn't have
to be as clean as the other ones like
you can say [ __ ] on Conan and the first
one I had this set I had a [ __ ] and a
dick and he goes you have to pick [ __ ]
or dick you can't say [ __ ] and dick it
still needs to be kind of clean we can't
have both I was just like let me know
which one you want to say I love comedy
and I cut out the cut out [ __ ]
yep the dick okay because I ran it
without a and that's some of the things
I was like I'm gonna run it with only
[ __ ] and then no more with only dick
yeah and dick work better than [ __ ] how
many times you think he ran that set
that exact set was a lot because that's
a set I did in Montreal so I ran it it
was pretty close to the set I did at the
festival and then it was pretty close to
the set I was doing in Atlanta at the
time like a 5-7 minute set and those
were all I've been doing a lot of those
jokes for at least like a year maybe two
and then there was a couple of new bits
in there which I didn't expect him to
like I was just like all those in new or
whatever he goes no that that needs to
be in the set and I was like that mm-hmm
so I was a little surprised by some of
his choices but for the most part I was
like I was building my late-night set
anyway as good as I could guess what it
would be like and so he only made a
couple of cuts like what well he would
be like well like and he has very
interesting theories for why you should
cut certain things and he would use
terms like going back to the well like
if you have similar punchlines I was
like this is one where you talk about
something stuff to them and then at the
end you kind of pull out the rug and be
like because I was the thing the thing
and then and it's like a reveal of like
that's funny because you didn't know the
entire time that it was my mom or some
or whatever that it's not a doctor he's
a janitor yeah and then if you're if you
have another one like that he's like
well those are similar so within five
minutes if you get two laughs that are
two the same I don't think it'll hit as
hard
even if it does well it's like for a for
a five-minute piece it's it doesn't make
as much sense and at which i think is
true yeah and it's not something I
really thought about before we would
work on sets and he also really likes
especially for a late night set I think
about classic classic stand up like like
one of the jokes I would do this just
easy to remember
he's like Funt like in the second one
where I said people think I'm a nice guy
but it's really just that I'm from the
south and I treat everybody like they
have a gun which is like a quick little
it's not all tea it's not care it's just
me saying a thing like people think this
but really it's this and it's like oh
and that always gets a laugh like and
this one of those ones where I was like
I bet he's gonna like that hey that's
that's a guy in front of a curtain on TV
oh yeah like it's just a classic thing
but he also likes weird stuff but I
think he likes a mixture of it and I
would loved I like getting different
kinds of laughs like I would have liked
that there's a one-liner here's a big
act out of my dad here's something silly
here's just to have a variety so that
people like oh this guy's you know he's
got a bit whole bag of tricks say he can
do more than just a kickflip yes he can
like grind and like do a backflip right
anybody with that's showcasing your
talent for an audience you want it you
want to showcase it you don't just want
to show them you know you wouldn't
juggle for five minutes you juggle and
you balance something on your head and
then you do a flip
you would never Erika's got talent like
everyone has to like here's here's well
here's a few things I can do that's gold
yeah that even for like your submission
tape into one of these late-night shows
yeah that's that's something you want to
check off the list yeah show them a
little bit of what you got you know
because you're saying hey to even though
I'm not it's not like everyone in
America watches it but comedy fans you
know a lot of people watch Conan on line
and stuff and it's kind of your intro to
hey I'm I'm in the scene I'm in the mix
here and I mean for me it was I was
hoping people would see me on cone and
be like I want to book them at my club
mm-hmm
that happened it did it took a while but
uh you know people that I've seen it and
I think a lot of clubs they sit down and
they book their whole year in one week
like one sitting there just like boom
boom boom boom boom and then it's done
and but yet now it's like to me it was
an odd conan was great but uh I feel
like the Conan clip existing on the
Internet is like an audition a permanent
audition tape like oh maybe he'd be fun
for this or this web series or maybe he
could write on this you know it's just
out there forever for people to look at
yeah it's a good quality tape to have
and yeah of you submitting it from like
this shaky camera in the back of a bar
it's like no here's me presented
professionally with good audio mm-hmm
good good video and a nice overarching
kind of experience of what my like
workflow is yeah and I think people like
cuz I mean that's why I felt before I
did Conan I was like watch those Clips
oh yeah this guy but yeah it was a fun
it was a fun experience for sure
yeah both times very exciting after
seeing you on Conan like you said it's
like I moved to LA and then got on Conan
too much it kind of lets you know what's
possible yeah so even seeing you get on
Conan it was like oh yeah people do it
like I was just talking him it's it's
not there's like we can take this myth
it took the mysticism out of like
climbing Mount Conan or whatever yeah
and like it was a goal for a while but I
think I had the wrong intention where I
was like I want to be on cone and so
comics think I'm cool but right I want
to do it now for like like you showed me
it's possible select I want to do it
from Atlanta to be like look it is
possible just like dusty slate from
Nashville yeah yeah has been on Kimmel
and Fallon while living out of Nashville
oh yeah so it's inspirational yeah it's
very inspirational and it's a it's just
a crazy thing it's crazy to be able to
for it to be because as a kid I would
see comedians on late-night and be like
these are gods yes or like just like
know that not just people there's people
doing stand-up I mean I remember well
when Atlanta had the improv
I won't say his name because the dudes
hilarious but he had just come out with
a half-hour
he was headlining The Improv that
weekend and it did not go well
and you like see me as a half-hour and
then it was not the hour he had a half
hour but that hour said yeah yeah but
yeah he didn't show them that other 30
minutes right
but yeah it's like people you you think
these people are bulletproof and it's
like nobody's bulletproof yeah everybody
can bomb and it's gonna happen I love
its
it never doesn't entertain me where I'm
like there goes yeah you just had one
yeah oh yeah I'm gonna have one some
more yeah we all I keep having them yeah
but he'll got booed a couple that's what
keeps me I'm like Chappelle got booed a
couple years ago everybody bombs yeah
okay it's just sometimes it just doesn't
work you know what are some of the main
reasons do you have you found that maybe
it just doesn't work that night
sometimes you are just not matching the
mood you're just you really um have you
ever you ever kissed someone and their
lips are like cold and you're like oh no
they're dead but you're just like mate
you both want to kiss
you're both you you both would like to
you both like each other but it's just
the chemistry just doesn't and maybe it
was good before but it's just like this
is just not the night for us
this is not working out you know or
sometimes you'll just eat something be
like I'm I'm sick eating this I don't
know what it is but sometimes it's just
something in the air and you're just
you're just meeting them you know I
don't know why it keeps coming back to
kissing but like you try to kiss someone
and then you just bump teeth and it
hurts
oh yeah just kind of takes the fun out
of it
and sometimes you just like this crowd
and miR and just not getting on that
same wavelength or like you should have
a dread of a dressed something and there
it at first there weirded out you didn't
address it or you fumbled a word and
then you did address it within that god
I'm distracted and they didn't get your
first punch line and then you'd you'd do
the next joke in a sort of a sour mood
because the first joke didn't go good
they're like oh I don't like this energy
yeah the sour energy and/or you didn't
watch the comedian before you didn't
watch their set and you you opened with
a similar joke to one of theirs and
they're like what didn't he now they're
confused like is he in this room or did
he just get here did he not know and now
they're distracted I mean there's so
many thing and then sometimes you just
don't know you're like I don't know what
I did wrong you know it's just like in a
relationship where you're like she's mad
no know what it is but or he sometimes
you recover and sometimes you just go
down in flames yeah yeah and then you
just got to take those else because they
happen and you learn from them I mean
they're totally it makes you better or
maybe it doesn't I don't know how I say
that just so hope so hopes I think
bombing makes you better for sure I
think you learn from your failures yeah
do you find the more confident you are
on stage almost the more confident the
audience will be in you and then like
when the confidence shrinks like if one
joke misses and your comment starts to
shrink then the audience starts to
shrink do you find that unless it's part
specifically party or persona that
you're like a nervous like twitchy
comedian or something or like your thing
is that you're like a sheepish you know
see you see people do that but they're
still delivering that character like if
you're auditioning for a role of
sheepish guy you can still go in there
and crush that audition and someone can
be doing a bad job of being sheepish and
not get that part right so I've seen
people that like Adam Sandler I love and
he's got that great like yeah you know
like but he's killing it at that he's
not you know he's he's really delivering
on that persona and you know I think a
crowd can tell when you're like big dick
swinging hey this is a killer opener
this is my killer follow-up and I'm you
know I'm doing this and I think they
have a good time that way you know it's
like a rock star wouldn't be like
this is a good guitar like you know
you've got to sell it if it fits your
persona though I think self-awareness is
a big part in standing yeah you got to
know how they see you and yeah what you
look like yeah you seem like and how you
take the stage how were you able to
discover that for yourself
failure I'd be like what I really
thought I could be like Eddie Murphy and
I just realized that
oh he's Eddie Murphy and I'm Kaleb and I
like I can't be Eddie Murphy and I
shouldn't want to be I need to be me
mm-hmm and it's still a work in progress
but it's like once you realize what
you're like and you watch yourself on
stage and you watch people react to you
and oh this is a way I can win them over
I can't come out guns blazing all the
time sometimes you got to bring them in
and then ramp it up and every crowd is
different because it's a different
combination of people on a different day
and some days you get you gotta say
something some days it's like I mean
politics is always a thing where it's
like you sometimes you got to address
that it's weird if you don't sometimes
it's weird if you do they're like come
on we had enough right now you just kind
of have to gauge it and be a person in
the world like our people sick of this
kind of thing are they not sick of it um
you see some people that do like 1980
style gay jokes and it's like I think
people are sick of that for sure I don't
know if you're like fingers on the pulse
anymore but uh it seems like it seems
like you've never met a gay person in
your life you really think that okay
it's just and you can tell the crowds
like we liked you and then you said that
and sometimes you can tell the second
someone loses a crowd and they don't
know they did but they know they're gone
they're like which one and you can see
them being like oh but uh sometimes it's
like you were killing it and then you
like it's like you just like surprise
the crowd with a finger in their ass and
they're like no it's like I mean we
liked it but then you did that and hmm
yeah I discovered when I got angry like
genuinely angry uh the crowd would shut
down I get sarcastically angry but I
would find I would lose audiences in the
middle of a set if I was just
like you started like getting angry
about something like nowise babyface
yeah b-boy getting angry like it didn't
translate with what my like delivery
system is yes and it's sometimes it's
people think they're doing a better job
of masking their anger than they are hmm
and it's like that's even where it when
when when you're like oh he doesn't know
we know the crowds once they feel like
you're not in charge or oh he thinks
he's in sure like it's like a mutiny
they're like uh you don't tell us what
to do anymore
and it's but and sometimes you can tell
the host walks back up and they're like
it's almost like they're in on it with
the host like II they host knows he
didn't he didn't get us and it's we I
hate that feeling when you bomb then the
host goes back home goes well no even if
there are nice us and they don't like
roast you afterwards he's like alright
and then you hear them do a joke and get
them back and sometimes you open really
big and then every joke after that just
sequentially worst yeah and you're like
boy ten minutes ago yeah it's the worst
how have you been able to in your
experience sometimes you can get them
back and sometimes you never wrestle
them back but what have you found to be
effective in wrangling them back in
well there's it depends on what lost
them like sometimes I'll lose them I'll
go too dirty too quick huh and they
don't trust me yet or they don't like me
yet you know I haven't I
I was doing good but I was doing good
cuz I had some solid jokes and then I'm
like alright let's do some dirty jokes
and they're like we don't we don't know
yet I don't know about that we're
laughing earlier but it wasn't cuz we
like you is cuz the jokes and now that's
something we need to like you for right
right now like that episode of Seinfeld
where he's like you want to help me move
and he's like I don't know if we're
there on our friendship yet and that you
just kind of jump the gun on certain
things or
so I try to figure out okay and
sometimes it's hard in the moment on the
fly like to be like well I gotta I gotta
try this but a lot of times addressing
it and being like talking to the crowd
for a minute or interacting with them or
you know just being real first like the
other night at the laughing so I was
just like I was kind of felt like I
didn't like my last set that I was good
but I just didn't really feel like in it
like I wanted to yeah cuz you know how
it feels not like I've done that Club
enough to know how it feels when you're
really cooking and I was like I just
didn't feel like I was really in there
and then the next set I was like cuz
what was on my mind because you know
when you can talk to someone they're
just not there with you you're like oh
you're thinking about your taxes or
something right we're not connecting and
I was I was really think because I
hadn't seen any of the Brian Kemp Stacey
Abram stuff I'd been keeping up with the
California stuff and I hadn't followed
the join the Georgia race and then
people were showing me stuff all day
like you haven't seen these Brian camp
ads and they're shown to me and they
made me laugh so hard because I couldn't
believe they were real he literally said
I got a big truck in a political ad he
told us he had a big truck it made me in
kill me that's all I could think about
then I was like if I were if this crowd
were my friends and I want them to feel
like they're my friends if I was meeting
them in a bar which this is we're
drinking I would go have you guys seen
that Brian Kemp [ __ ] like that's how I
would talk to my friends even if this
doesn't kill I want to talk to them
about this because this is on my mind
all day to day and it would feel weird
to not let this out and I can do my
prepared stuff other otherwise but uh
and that really made it put me in a good
mood it did well the rest of my set did
better than my set before I just needed
to say it and that made it more
conversational yeah I like more cuz like
the person you're hanging out we're
hanging out that's the that's the the
allure of stand-up is like oh he's just
thinking of all this conversationally
it's the magic trick yeah and sometimes
I see some crowds are easier to fool
than others and someone want to be
fooled though it's like going to see a
magician oh yeah and I had this bit I do
like I try not to wear glasses on stage
so I can use my eyes more but I'd like
to do theirs
an impression of Mike Pence I do with my
glasses but if I don't have them on
I'll just take someone's glasses and use
it like that like can I borrow your
glasses for this impression and last
night someone this lady was just super
drunk it was a birthday she had a big
birthday sash oh my god she's like just
like talking in between every joke and
she's drunk and she's like cleaning her
glasses and stuff and I'm like oh you're
not even watching me anymore you're
taking a break okay you're really
participating there you're like I don't
need to see him and so I was like can I
have those and I took her glass and then
people thought I thought of that because
she took her glasses off but I'm like
I've been doing this bit for like a year
but there people came to me like oh you
were so in the moment and then the thing
I was like I'm glad I didn't think that
but I mean when I saw the glasses I was
like this is gonna be perfect this is
gonna look so fun and organic and it was
fun cuz I was like oh yeah that reminds
me of my bit with the glasses can I I
didn't tell her that I was just like oh
let me have these and then right did it
and it people thought oh it's like it's
so cool but uh it's just that's part of
the thing of like being a committee
there's a reason they came to see you
live and then just watch you on YouTube
they can do that for free
mm-hmm but uh to give them a little
something like I don't have anything
about Brian Kemp on YouTube because it's
new to me
so it's just fun to be able to interact
with them sometimes have you been able
to find cuz your style is I mean you're
only seven years in I mean you've been
on Conan twice and Comedy Central and
Last Comic Standing all this jazz they
leave anything out is anything else you
want to boast laughs on Fox laughs
laughs laughs I'm fine perfect perfect
I taped a a Bossip special that never
aired that's my claim to fame oh and I
taped roast battle that never aired
either so oh yeah grateful both never
came out in hindsight oh yeah very
grateful but um in you being so early in
the comedy you have been able to seem
like you have you've you've clearly you
know I've interviewed people 15 years in
who are like you know I think I'm just
now starting to get this comedy thing so
at every level I think we're always like
well it could be better way
you know I think oh I discovered this
part about me that I like performance
style or whatever but you being only
seven years in and seeming to be like
you've found your quote voice at least
it lives more than most people at your
level how have you able to do that would
you say um well I mean I'm chipping away
at it I'm not where I want to be yet I
mean one of the cool things about LA is
I'll see everyone there's a lot of great
comedians in LA but all the best
comedians from London New York Atlanta
everyone at some point you got to be
there for something or do you just want
to be there for something because it's
like it's a place that you go yeah even
if you don't live there you go there
sometimes so I mean I get to see almost
every comedian I want to see almost
everybody who's really great and I mean
I'm like I was on the stage I where I've
been on that stage and I know what it
sounds like when I'm up there and it
doesn't sound that good like I'll be
like I do not kill like that hmm and the
people you see kill like that they're
always like 20 years in whoo I'm like
that is like they're doing some work
that is like wow and so I still know
like even though I've done some things
and I've further along than I thought
I'd be I still don't have that 20 years
in like master of comedy feel Oh totally
uh so I think I've I'm like I just
chipped away in and found a little bit
of gold but I don't feel like I'm like
in the zone like you know bill burr oh
no I wasn't trying to imply I was just
saying only seven years in you seem to
be like ahead of the curve in terms of
development so I didn't know if there
was specific techniques or tips you have
for other communions maybe how what
you've had to learn the hard way you
could kind of share with them well this
helped me or listening back on my set
that helped me develop this style or
like you know what I mean well I am I
it's it's like saying oh you got it's
like the old days when people literally
had to go to like Oregon Trail to
California you know what I mean
and I went without anything I went with
like a bag and a horse I didn't have a
carriage and a family and like all this
stuff and it they're like well you got
pretty far I'm like yeah but I don't
have anything hmm you know what I mean
and I don't I'm not I put every part of
my life on hold because I had that
option at the time you know starting at
19 it's like I have I it's easy for me
to drop everything because I don't have
anything right I had to I brought my two
bags of stuff to LA you moved with your
girlfriend right okay
I have since broken up so no that's fine
oh I didn't know that
oh yes I well you know I'm not on
Facebook like that well we didn't do a
breakup post but uh okay I could use
four hundred likes I love a good breakup
post you ever read those yeah yeah I
don't I don't really I'm not on Facebook
like that yeah it's uh I people like
think they gotta do a press release
they'll be like you may have heard that
is funny you you mentioned before the
show one of your um you posted about
bombing on stage and that got more likes
then your post about getting yeah yeah
which is funny well people people love
when you do Conan a lot of people are
happy for you a lot of people are not a
lot of people like this guys doing Conan
mmm you know what I mean like there's
that that's a thing and it's also
there's nothing that funny about that
you can be funny on corner but saying
I'm doing Conan it's not that funny to
say and you could try and make it like a
fun goofy post like oh yeah I'm doing
Conan but I gotta still got up tomorrow
cuz you can kind of make it a
light-hearted thing but no one's like
laughing out loud at your Conan
announcement but like I did one the
other day where I said I I just bombed
so bad the crowd asked me how I was
doing tonight
mmm which is like a Dangerfield desk leg
which is just funny like why would the
the girls like are you okay and that got
more likes than either time I did
because I think people were like ah how
you know he's a drain everybody bombs
and comedians relate to it people who
don't do comedy are still like yeah I've
seen people bomb like that's a painful
experience but he's making light of it
it's just more fun to I love talking
about bombing cuz it it's hilarious to
me have you ever been booed yeah
what's what is your worst cuz I loved
how about bombing which I think I may
have started this before you were on hot
breath but I now ask every guest their
worst bomb story cuz I love talking
about bombing and laughing at people's
bombing expense yes this story but um
it's a it was when I was in Kentucky
Louisville Kentucky was my first feature
weekend I was very excited to do it I
was doing thirty minutes five shows and
the first show I bombed bad for thirty
minutes I bomb so bad that I
accidentally did a joke twice but it
didn't matter bomb the first and second
time just like all the other jokes like
dead silence icy stony silence stares
frown how many people there's a full
Club I mean I may be hundred fifty okay
that Club is and so I did and and all
the jokes I was doing I mean I I was
trying everything I think I did every
joke I'd ever thought of because you
guys probably did an hour and 15 minutes
I was doing things I've been like maybe
I've I've never even said this out loud
but I'm out of things to say right well
you guys can everything shrink oh yeah
and so I did like all my jokes and and I
you know would have my premature
ejaculator joke little penis joke I'm
broke doing taxes Joe nothing nothing
everything dirty jokes clean jokes
everything bombs and the headliner goes
up and uh he crushed he goes up there
and goes give it up for Caleb he's he's
got a little dick he comes fast he's
broke pieces yeah give it up for him
they laugh so hard
him summarising me and roasting me they
laugh so any crushed
and so the next night I go uh I'm like
man I ate [ __ ] I gotta switch it up and
so I'm like going through all my
notebooks and stuff and so I do a
different 30 minutes set and that bombs
too but the headliner didn't watch me
the second time he's just having a drink
in the bar he assumed I did the same set
so he goes up and goes give it up for
kill you got a little dick he comes fast
it's a broke pieces and they the crowd
like was furious with him you could hear
him going like oh like you're like well
you're so me he wasn't funny but that's
not nice to say about him whoa and then
he bombed cuz so I bomb
I bombed so bad I like ruined his mic
but that's awareness like you said
earlier he didn't watch my taking the
temperature of the room but that was one
of the worst bombs ever had cuz I when
you bomb so bad you you repeat a joke
and then it there's no recovering from
that I mean it was like and I to have
your whole act bomb where I was like oh
none of me you guys don't like any of me
you guys don't like my riffs you don't
like my crowd work you don't like my new
jokes my old jokes
you don't like yeah like that is a full
rejection and the 30 minutes is long
enough to where you're like oh I didn't
get him in five but maybe if I would
have had a longer set I was like nope
nope there was nothing I just failed hey
yeah bombed in a 30-minute set and it's
like quicksand about 15 minutes in after
it feels like an hour 15 yeah I looked
down and I'm like every time you try to
fight you get deeper and deeper into the
quick-set oh yeah and then it's just
like what I sometimes I'll be like
there's a way out and I can't find it
it's just not that skilled yet I just
don't have the enough tools in my
toolbox yet to find my way out and
there's some people that you even when
they bomb they eventually find their way
out a little bit right and you'll be
like like the whole bilborough's always
the exact cuz like his whole thing his
persona is such a [ __ ] you guys thing
anyway that when he bombs you kind of
like glad you're like huh you want him
to look at the crown back oh yeah yeah
Oh too much fur and then and then he's
like then he starts going in on you like
oh we're at the Comedy Store
if whatever it is is funny but that's
like we can think about you have a bill
burr does this but then it's like that's
like looking at Tom Brady right rowing
like a 50-yard touchdown like but he
throws the football just I got to a
football yeah both throw throw oh [ __ ]
oh no oh no fonta swatters
that's how mad I get when you bring up
Tommy oh you know do we have a towel
yeah Caleb
well I only wanted to drive home the
merch Bob does water cleans up well this
is a what's really funny is this is
probably what people are gonna remember
about the podcast nothing um I'm sorry
guys anything else oh I don't even see
that again I just saw it missed the plug
so I didn't panic is that cord all right
oh okay that's why I like played it off
because like okay there's nothing
getting wet down there but then I was
like oh the mic cord yeah where it's
connected well
shout out to a Mon garner shout out bold
coy podcast network you think after all
these shows there's always a bottle of
water I still don't know how to use one
so you know even like every now I would
notice when I was taking a drink I would
like to put the lid back on I know is
your lid wasn't on oh boy but I didn't
want to disrupt your old comedy couldn't
have disrupted much more than what I
just did we're talking about bombing and
then you bomb that's a real bomb in a
studio as we time out bombing you're
like well let's bomb here - yeah I can I
can ruin anything
I won't boo you though you did say you
got booed uh yeah the last time I got
booed I just like I assumed that guy
assumed all I used to do a lot more
political stuff than I do now I mean I
like to talk about Paula Paula that kind
of gives you the freedom to talk about
it cuz sometimes you can really lose a
crowd with political you can lose a
crowd that agrees with you with
political stuff cuz they're just tired
of hearing yeah and they just don't want
to deal with it that day but one time I
mean I just really guess I misjudged it
and I was like I had these political
jokes
and I and I I should have just told the
jokes but sometimes you feel like you
have to go hey um you know explain your
beliefs before but I realize didn't have
to it one time I was just like yeah I
voted for Hillary Clinton but I and then
I had these Hillary Clinton jokes which
I thought it goes oh you like if you
love Hillary you're like I don't want to
make it fun of Hillary but I was like no
I voted for so but I do have jokes but
I'm on your team so don't worry right
and and if you hate Hillary hey I voted
for but I do have some jokes about it
I'm not blind to the humor of you know
making fun of her or whatever so which I
thought was reasonable but the crowd
started booing before I got to finish
the premise they booed me for voting for
and I was like wow yeah but is I'm about
to tell a joke about it like I'm not
this isn't a rally and then I just
realized like I don't know if I should
even bother with saying it because to
get booed for like what and then the
rest of my set just blew they just hate
it like like they were just like I don't
know if it was it was all everyone in
that crowd was either Trump or Bernie or
something and they just hate and they
just did not want me saying that the
fact the quick reaction sure like expect
politics can be divisive but there are
some jokes you do where I'll have a
feeler where it's like okay if they
laugh at the first part of the joke I'll
go into the three tags but if they don't
laugh at the first part I will veer off
to yes I will abandon any joke for sure
but then I kind of learned from that
world's like you know a lot of people
have political jokes almost everyone's
got these I want to show the crowd more
of my thing instead of I mean it's like
every late-night comedian has them yeah
and they're doing it at the high level
that everyone sees and there's what 10
of those shows so if you want that watch
that or you know go see Louis black or
whoever you you like to get your
political comedy from sounds like it's
not really my thing it's not how I I'm
not like it's caleb the political
comedian so it's not like part of my I
don't have to do it and I was like I
just feel like it's kind of a waste of
time and it pisses people off more than
anything that's self-awareness yeah
again even though I thought I had some
pretty funny Trump and Hillary stuff
and Bernice I thought I had like
interesting takes but I just I I don't
know if it was worth it for how often it
scuttled my whole set and that's why I
found is like I would for a little while
I was trying to have a message and be
like outsourcing labor to China kids are
making iPhones and like the jokes were
funny but they weren't really connected
to me and I found when I started to get
more personal with my material I have
found ways to start weaving that point
of view in but it wasn't just some kid
up there just be like this is what's
happening what's wrong now that it comes
through me instead of me like pointing
at it I found that can help like kind of
make it a little more palatable yeah
well you don't want to come across it's
a crazy guy yelling on the street yeah
you know and so it comes with you starts
handing you something and they got a big
sign and you're like ah I'm not gonna
listen to anything you say because
you're surprising me in your shock and
you're making me uncomfortable but if
one of your friends goes hey man you
know what they're doing it's really
[ __ ] up and you gotta help me out and
I'm like oh yeah that is no no you put
it that way but the hole in your I'm
just not in your face and some comedians
are like that's their style is in your
face and I'm just like I have to kind of
act like I just thought of it more like
oh it's not oh oh I wonder if I'll
because I can't I can't do the Louis
black thing oh yes so it's almost like
you you you can say it but it's more
unassuming it's not as like it's not as
personified maybe I don't that's the
word and I pulled out my liberal arts
degree for them no I think I know what
you mean
you know it like Louis black is like I'm
angry and saying this and you should
listen but if you you said a little more
just sly and a little more like subtly
it comes off better than just this is
what's wrong
yeah okay yeah - go like - I like to act
like like if I were going after
something I think is wrong in the world
I would I would go for it in a story and
be like here's an examined to me the
other day and this guy didn't and then
like tell them about a thing that
happened that oh they tried that and it
didn't work
which is a part of the bigger reason
this this ideology I think doesn't work
though okay great but instead of being
like if you think this you're dumb I'll
go this guy did this it didn't
work this guy is dumb not you or whoever
you voted Foreman like and then kind of
cuz no one wants to listen to you and
your side are stupid or you and what you
believe are stupid or you know the
people don't like that as much yeah I
learned from a Royale Benes I worked
with him at punchline few like last year
maybe now but he was like EP of daily
show for a long time and now he's doing
stand-up mm-hmm and I I like had these
had these more like political jokes or I
was like telling this crowd at the
punchline like 50-year old parents how
the world works and he's like think
about how you're coming off on stage
like you're like this young dude trying
to tell these people how the world works
yeah it's like think about how like what
you're saying thing about how it's
coming across through the filter of you
and that really changed kind of how I
deliver and how I approach material well
I you know you got to think about what
is Joel what how do how what made me get
into comedy who was I making laughs when
I had that thought you know what what
what do I like about making people laugh
what makes me laugh and to be more
genuine because it's like I didn't get
into at me and my friends before I did
stand-up we weren't sitting around
talking about China right never did that
right it's like we're just you know and
what you find funny can evolve and stuff
but it's like I remember what what I
what I actually like to do and what I
actually think is funny instead of what
what I'm like utilitarian like oh I had
I said that and that's funny and you
know to try and really be yourself so
you pay attention to how you're funny in
conversation and take note of those yeah
cuz I think that's more me then stage me
but I want stage me to be as close to me
as I can which it's not what a Steve
Martin is amazing but it's you know his
whole thing is a character that's that's
really funny but um I I'm trying to be
more um even if it's silly me like like
even if even if I'm being dumb I want to
be dumb the way I'm dumb in real life
right away I'm
be like playing an idiot when I'm
hanging out with my friends because
that's my fit well that's still the
funniest thing in the world to me is to
act like you don't know something just
be in it be like Oh or like oh that's oh
wait oh be and then they're like oh no
you idiot that's fun to me
and that makes my friends laugh so I'm
like that's probably that's all I know
is effective really so maybe that's how
and like kind of circling back to you
only seven years in but finding a unique
style about you at least maybe part of
that is just paying attention to what
and how you're funny in real life yeah
and then taking that to the stage yeah
sure some like I one of the ones this
doesn't really work I tried it onstage
like once or twice it worked okay but uh
I was talking one of my friends about
politics something he was like I don't
know she's kind of a radical feminist
and I don't really know if I agree with
that I was like radical feminist I was
like what does that mean she wants
rights really bad and like everybody
laughs because I know that's not what it
means but the first thought I had about
it was like what makes it radical like a
non radical feminist like I want them
but I'm not gonna try I don't want all
these rights but turns out what it
actually means it's not funny at all
it's someone who they're feminist but
they don't believe trans women deserve
oh yeah they're like oh you were they
they're like no you were born a man you
don't is it so that like a radical
feminist is like radical yeah yeah but
uh so anyway but that's just one of the
things we're like I knew it didn't mean
that but saying oh is that what this
mean and then people laugh that's funny
to me too my dumb first thought and but
then going oh that's probably not what
it means but pretending I didn't realize
it yeah
is that's one of my favorites to do is
all but even like your first on your
first conan set your opening joke was
something that just came out in
conversation they ended up opening up
conan with yeah so it's like when you
when you have these moments like when
you are funny in real life do you write
these down you type in your phone like
keep track of them yes um I I still fool
myself several times a year and go
that's so funny that's like my new
closer that's the best idea I've ever
had
only need to write that down all right
forget it ten minutes later yep and I'm
like what was it I remember sit and I'll
be like huh like that so I try really
hard to write it down or put it my phone
as soon as I have the thought even if
people like oh you write and then down
you write more here hits now you think
you're gonna because people will make
fun of you and be like oh is this a bit
you're doing a bit is it a bit yeah I'm
like yeah it's my job yeah you guys all
laughed and that's my job
so maybe what I said to y'all could work
from other people sorry this is the most
work I have to do is two seconds to put
it into my phone so and that's something
I'm having a Noah garden store it's on
here
yeah it was he was talking about honor
the thought he's like I hate it if it's
2:00 in the afternoon or 2:00 in the
morning he's like if you think it's
funny honor it by writing it down yes
don't just be like uh maybe not or I'll
remember it later he's like no honor
that idea and at least give it the
justice of writing it down yeah because
I mean it's a it's a hard job but how
hard is that you know how hard is
writing your thoughts down right it's
pretty easy so give it a shot and I
still I mean I know this it's one thing
you know it's like knowing McDonald's is
bad and I'm still eating it of course
two weeks later like well I'm still
alright I'll never learn and then even
more I'm like how do I learn a lesson
and still not learn it how do I know
what to do it's still good mmm maybe it
just wasn't time to learn yeah you know
no but yes I'm better about it than I
used to be but uh still not perfect I
still think I've forgotten the three of
the best jokes I've ever thought of but
even even for like when you do a set on
Conan I had my interview Jacob Williams
on here who was on Colbert and he said
there was an actual there was a
teleprompter with his setlist is that
the same at Conan as well they give you
that option I didn't use it because I
didn't want to uh I didn't want to look
back at the clip and be like oh that's
me looking back at the Atilla you know
what I mean oh yeah I was like I if I
can't remember these five jokes I don't
need to be on this and some people are
different
I'm sure it's comforting to know I'm not
going to forget my spot
but for me I'm like most of my jokes are
about a minute long so I only need to
remember like five some people have
those quick Joe where I'm like I'm glad
you had you would need that if you have
like maybe 13 quick jokes yeah you
wouldn't want to forget them but for me
I was like I've run this set so many
times I won't need it but even down to
like gestures and like how dialed is in
is like that Conan set like down there
like every breath you've pretty much
choreographed pretty much yeah and which
is what I would want I'm there's some
that are like in the second one I had
that the bit I closed as was about being
pitched a terrible joke which was I love
doing that bit because it's it's me
telling you someone telling me a bad
joke so laughing or not laughing is
funny because of that so that was that
bit as fun because sometimes it goes
different just based on when they laugh
and why they laugh and you know how they
laugh this is just a different kind of
thing so that one wasn't as dialed in
because it was like who knows how it'll
go it always got a laugh at the end but
I was like getting there was so fun cuz
you never know when they're gonna
realize the how bad it is
so yeah it's fun to have some that
aren't as scripted but for the most part
it's like you know all the way through
even like I noticed because I'll use
your first conan set is like a case
study in my comedy class where I'm like
we'll look at that before and after
versions of these jokes are doing and
one of the main differences is you
condense the set up and you're talking
way slower way slower like slowing down
onstage I found power in it but there's
also still a hesitation of I'm gonna
slow down oh I figured it out and then
one time slowing down isn't quite
working then you speed back up and you
get jittery again like have you found
that to be a big difference in your
comedy yes I'm crowds uh some crowds are
laser-focused in and like a very polite
quiet good focused crowd
and those are the ones that I like to uh
you can kind of take it slow or you just
kind of feel it out how it's going like
it's like you kind of build them up and
then okay we got the ship going now we
can turn or whatever and then there's
some cows that are kind of rowdy and you
kind of got to get them hmm
up top and then you can bring them in
and kind of like slow it down or
something but uh it just depends on what
they're like like I would definitely for
like a bar crowd I would be faster
louder quicker and dirtier because
that's what it's that's what being in a
bar is like interesting you're yelling
at your friends about sex over beers
usually that's what's happening so why
would I why would I treat it differently
than what it is we're in a bar but if
you're in a theater and there's all
kinds of plays but when you're in a
theatre it's just a different feeling
than a in a bar or a comedy club but
just to match the venue like um match
the venue match the venue match the
audience match the energy you know if so
the guy before you was doing fast loud
and dirty and it wasn't working you
might not should do that mm-hmm you know
it might seem a he may have guessed
wrong he was like oh fast loud and dirty
and then nope nope you misjudged it and
and that's why it's great to go last
going last is pretty great cause you get
to see a lot of failure before you
you're also like you're touring around
and headlining a lot now and in looking
at the business side of comedy way in
our first interview you talked a lot
about even just your opportunities like
you would just email everyone even Last
Comic Standing you got the audition from
just emailing them yeah so yeah I was
all I've always been impressed with your
ability to network and navigate that
aspect of quotes show business you know
the shows a job the business as a job as
well you have to be good at both so now
that you're out in LA like we're kind of
some of the business practices you've
learned from being out there la is a
specific beast and you kind of got to
figure out how you fit in that Lane
everyone in LA Dave Ross told me that's
a great comedian very funny guy in LA
and he was like because I always hate
when people move to LA and go it's Hall
I'm like what did you think what did you
think right you think cuz the sun is
shining that changes it it'll surf in
like no no one is surfing people are
hunched over their computers trying to
beat the game you know and he's like
this is the final level this is the boss
level it's hard
why would beating the game be easy
everyone here is trying to make it
people who made it in New York move here
to try and make it here you know we're
trying to get no one here was trying to
get less famous so I think about that
all the time and it's like what what do
I offer you cuz I didn't move here it's
like the old I didn't come here to make
friends thing it's like I do have like
friends and I would like friends
I like making new friends but that's not
why I moved to LA I know why I moved
there I moved there to advance my career
and do LA specific things that I could
only do there you know TV I mean now
it's internet broadcast out to a larger
audience and find who's doing that and
how do they see me and I hope they want
to do that with me I hope they want to
work with me or someone I can work with
to broadcast ourselves you know out
somewhere so you always think about what
can I offer someone and I try not to
think about what they come out for me as
much as what I can offer them so let's
go save old JFK thing like ask what you
can do for your country so I'm like what
can I do for LA and a lot of times it's
a that I'm reliable and I'm available a
lot of people like don't tell people
you're available
I'm available I'll seem busy and we went
talking about so maybe I'm doing it
wrong I don't know but what's been
working for me is that um I show up on
time and I like to hang out I like to
have fun and I always try and you know
people put me first on shows a lot
because I you know I probably am NOT
gonna fin
that many people as long as longer not
in a church or something and by the way
I'll do a show in a church I've done it
before it's I'll just be clean it's not
a problem I've been in church yeah you
grew up your grew up in one group I can
do that yeah and I you know I try to fit
the thing and do it dude the job and in
LA there's also this economy of spots
everyone wants a diverse show no one
wants to be known as hey don't I don't
do that show they only booked straight
white guys you just don't want to have
that reputation in LA cuz they're like
oh well yeah you only like straight
white guys what do you you just wouldn't
want to be known as that so everyone
wants to have a diverse show but the
scene is overwhelmingly we're overrun
with straight white guys it is a big
chunk of the scene every show I go to
there's 15 standing in the back waiting
right you know it's just the supply and
demand there's way too many of them it's
like how can you stand out what can you
offer that they can't right and a lot of
times it's that I'm standing 15 feet
from the stage and if someone drops out
I'm right there but that if that's your
you know obviously if you're famous it's
different but it's like a lot of times
it's like we need to fill time you know
and I guess what I can feel some time
just like with Conan I mean they're like
oh we need you tomorrow you're like oh
okay I'll be there I'll be there you
don't need a flight or a hotel I'm just
right here yeah so and that's what
that's why I moved there is because I
need to be there cuz you know you might
not be everyone's first choice
that's why auditioning exists because
everyone has a first choice and you know
what Tom Cruise might be busy you know
that's how people get careers Tom Cruise
couldn't can't do every movie if he
could no one else would have a career he
would be in every movie because he's the
greatest and we all know it everyone
knows it he still looks 30 years old so
and that's literally auditioning
wouldn't exist if everyone had the first
choice auditions are filled with third
and fourth and fifth choices but you
better if you can be the fifth the best
fifth if you're a fifth choice and the
four couldn't do it
you got it it's you baby yeah so that's
the whole game to me is hey I'm getting
that mix and throw those dice as many
times as you can and you end up getting
stuff and you know work working hard and
trying and being pleasant to be around
is worth a lot you know if people if
everybody in LA has been everybody in LA
is pretty funny like you go to a show
you'd see ten comics they're all pretty
funny I remember two of their names
they're all pretty good but uh oh boy
after the show me and this guy hung out
he was a fun guy we went out and did
karaoke I went to a those and get and
then you get it hang out doesn't always
work I mean if you hang out and use [ __ ]
and suck they're like fun hang but we're
never booked home right right nightmare
and got booed so you still got to be
good but it's like some people just seem
too cool for school
and it's like you know like we're
talking about earlier festivals it's
like who do you want your festival do
you want you know guy who's on his phone
not hanging out before the show or after
the show is always like can I go early
and leave it's like you want to be here
at all like I threw this Fester because
I want to have some fun and comedies
finally if people forget sometimes this
is supposed to be fun this is the whole
point we're trying to entertain people
and it's easier if you're having a good
like that Sandler special never seen
anybody have that much fun he's having
so it makes you love him you're like
guys having a good time up there I
haven't seen it yet it's really funny I
like it a lot but yeah in LA that's
that's that's the way I've been trying
to do it and uh you know and it's also
like you know I try to be a genuine guy
I'm not trying to be like hey who wants
to have fun later who produces content
you know you try not to be like gross
you know I do like I'm always confused
when people don't hang after I'm like
what do you got tomorrow I know you
don't have a day job right I gotta get
home and get a good eight hours then
wake up and sit on my computer till my
show like what I've struggled dude
that's it took me a long time and I'm
still like trying
to be better at it and by trying that
means I'm not doing it clearly if you're
do they're doing it or not really no try
yeah like I wouldn't I would never hang
out I would always comedian and I'm I'm
the artist you know I gotta I just need
to do my stage time and leave like I
I've like never hung out and the few
times I have have been beneficial mm-hmm
but it's something I still I just don't
I just don't I don't know why but it's
well you want it to be organic and
that's what I love about LA people go oh
I hate LA I hate the actors and then and
I'm like I don't hang out with actors
talking about theirs you know what ten
million people live I don't know how
many people it's millions of people and
I'm like there's there's eight or ten
that I really dig and I hang out with
them and if they have friends we can
hang out but I'm not I'm not going who
put it you work at a paramount who but
ah ha no rest you do what you're
passionate about and do what you like
and have fun doing and you'll probably
run into people similar if you just do
it long enough somebody's like man I
really dig what you do you're a fun guy
I'd like to work with you it would be
fun
no one gets a hopefully you don't have a
show business job for other reasons why
would just go go to a business business
and make a lot of money you know instead
of betting on artists which is like who
even knows like sometimes there's 100
million dollars in a movie and no one
like something like whatever else yeah I
know so it's like it's such a crapshoot
but there's there's some cool people in
LA I know a lot of people like it's a
phony fake and all that and it's like
then of course it is every city's filled
with that kind of stuff but I found some
cool people out there that I like to
work with and it's uh it's a lot of fun
it's like if you're phony and fake
you'll attract the phony and fake yeah
you're real cool and authentic you'll
attract those people yeah and I you know
the way I my life the way I grew up is
like you know I'm a simple guy I want to
do my set and then hang out and have fun
after it and keep laughing with the
funniest people alive why would I not
take advance also
Nate bargatze bit weeds like Mauro it's
like oh you never laughed like that with
me and he goes I hang out my friends are
professional comedians it's a pretty
good time so it's like yeah I like this
I like I I would never want to just do
my set and Li I mean sometimes you have
to because of scheduling or whatever but
it's like I love the offstage part I
love hanging out with people and being
like like one of the cool things about
the Conan Booker's he's met and worked
with like every great comedian who think
of he's been doing that job for years
and he has so many fun inside stories
about what's happened behind the scenes
and it's like why wouldn't you want to
talk to that way why would you just use
him as a cog in your machine of like I
hope he likes this set so I can get in
get like he turns out he's a really cool
guy you don't want to just know this guy
like even if you never do Conan this is
a cool guy to know he's got great
stories and he's funny and he has great
take you don't just been I think people
can kind of tell when they're being used
yeah yeah people especially that level
the people you want to work with they
they know the DES and then they're like
scared of them like like oh I don't know
if I should talk so it's like what is
this high school might be come on I
think what helps is having goals as well
cos acting that'll give you direction
and almost confidence it may be not
being nervous because you have a goal to
get on Conan oh and you bump into the
Booker Conan you're like oh this is this
was supposed to happen it's not a go no
there he is it's like right oh no I'm
supposed to go talk to him because this
is part of my goals so I think goals can
almost be like a good credential to have
to kind of give you confidence to pursue
things that maybe outside of what's
possible
well it's awesome to be it'd be it'd be
a gentleman be a human being like if you
have a goal if there's someone you have
your eye on that you'd like to pursue
romantically you don't walk up to them
go hello
I'm interested in you in a romantic
situation it's a goal of mine like you
know get to know them talk to them see
if they feel the same way about you you
know like and it just seems like a
normal way to do it you know you don't
have to I hate when people go to me and
they just don't know I mean
it's not their fault but people would
come and be like I hear you booked a
show oh my girl I've been there
well I feel buy me a drink first you
know what I mean right so it's just to
be a be a polite decent person which is
doable what what's your name nice to
meet you Leo when can I do your show and
I like I don't even know who you are or
just think about what do I want to say
this person that's not a request like
thing it's mean to just do that um you
know so like for example Booker who I
know she I could never do that show when
she was booking it because what that
what he wanted why he hired her was he
was like I want to do debuts I want
up-and-coming comedians who have never
done late-night and I want them to do it
on Jimmy Kimmel and I couldn't do it
because I've already done Conan but I
didn't go oh well I'm never hanging out
with you what is in it for me it's like
no this is a late night TVs my favorite
thing I know one of the Booker's it's
fun to hang out with her she has great
stories she's fun
she does a great job so it's like to
just use people like Oh everyone's in
your life for a director eat like like
that I think that's a terrible way to be
and you can totally tell when people do
that it's just why would you want to
live your life that way it's like you
work hard and find some cool people and
it will if you're working hard and
you're hilarious it's not that no one
does that and gets nothing
totally not for long I mean it you know
eventually that'll take you somewhere
well I think you've showed today why you
are having such positive success in your
career so like early on and why it's
been some people can get one opportunity
but then that's it you know but even it
would actually build on each opportunity
and I think the things you've talked
about today really show why you're able
to sustain such momentum and how other
people can do the same positively and
not like trying to manipulate you know
yeah you can manipulate the crowd but ha
if you try and manipulate Booker's and
then just I mean
can I mean this is their job they can
they can see it coming just like anybody
can at any level it like you say even if
it's just like a local open mic Booker
they can tell the difference between you
being like Oh a spot verse I go here's a
cool person yeah
and if you go like if you go to a show
and just hang out there and enjoy it and
have fun like you should be doing with
your life like hey I'm a comedian I got
to open night
I'll go to this show it's fun I'll you
know have a drink support enjoy it you
know what you know who loves that the
person who runs that show 100% like
you're way more likely that is way more
likely to get you booked then
desperately and panicked like since
sending them an email and bugging them
or like and they're like oh you want to
do my show you've literally never been
to it right how bad you want to do it
you only know what it's like how do you
know you want to do it you just want to
use me like I just people just feel
gross and obviously that works for some
people at Isis and more emails than
anybody so it's like but you have to
know how you're coming just like how you
have to know how you're coming across on
stage like if everybody knows when they
see you walk into a party you're gonna
corner them and try and get something
out of them it's like people don't like
that and you know it's just like drawing
the crowd and like you know people like
hey I hear you want to do a I hear you
there's karaoke going on later you want
to do that that's what I like and it's
like I I probably am gonna get along
with that Booker more than the Booker
who doesn't like it cuz I we both like
it we'll enjoy working together more
than me and somebody who likes to you
know was more of a homebody yeah so in
in landing this plane because I you are
home here in the a in the a bit so I
don't want to monopolize all your time
but you mentioned moving to LA with the
goal of getting on Conan yeah you did
that within two months yeah
so in in closing this a little bit one
what are your goals now and how
important have goals been in continuing
to ascend the ladder if you will yeah
they're very important and the goals
doing Conan is a fun mm-hmm it's not
easy but it's it's a possible thing that
I've set clear goals for and then ended
up
so but the goals after that or harder I
think obviously I'd like to stand up
wise I'd like to eventually do like a
special and album do more late night
appearances things like that I'd also
love to do you know other thing I'd like
to do a series of some kind I'd like to
have a podcast or yeah I love doing
podcasts and I I do them pretty often
but I would like I mean I'd love to do
them like every day I think it's really
fun I love I love that medium so much
but uh yeah pitching shows I love movies
a lot but I feel like shows are more
kind of what I'd be interested in okay
movies that I mean obviously movies are
great but uh you have like now I have a
pilot oh yeah
you're ready yeah so getting a you know
pitching to different networks and stuff
and hopefully getting something picked
up but uh that's definitely a goal and a
special and stuff and I still have done
an album I know everybody has albums but
uh oh interesting yeah you haven't I'd
uh I just want to do it in conjunction
with something else because I got the
material but I want it to be like hey
here's the thing I've done either
special or a show or some thing and then
also here's this album if you like this
here's this thing I just wouldn't want
to do it without a without a companion
thing yeah I almost give context or like
something else for them to jump on to
even just a podcast if I I just don't
have you know I do the stand-up but I'm
also like you know I want the aisle to
be heard by as many people as can hear
it so I want it to be along with
something to kind of help it smart yeah
cuz I don't think it's like comedy
albums go viral something has to go
viral then oh I like this thing yeah
I'll get the album it's almost just like
something to have on the resume again
it's like checking it off the list
it's like oh you did I mean like it's
not like you do Conan and then now all
the sudden you're starting to sell out
Madison Square Garden right you know but
it is like oh okay check that off the
list got that on the resume
here Oh like it's being just a stand up
isn't it does it seem to be enough it's
like oh you're funny on stage what else
right what else do you do well I would
like to do I mean I like to do nothing
all day it's fun but not every day I'd
like to do nothing half the year and
then half the year I like stand up at
night and I'd like half of my days of my
year to be filled with you know you know
shooting something writing something
getting you know things like that done
but yeah I also love having like a whole
week of just nothing during the day
stand-up and I love that you did mention
in when you were talking to my class
earlier which I'll post on the Friday of
this release we'll post that as an extra
podcast but you're about being in the
writers room and how it's good pay but
you're literally there like it's a 24/7
oh there's a reason the pay is good
uh-huh cuz they're squeezing every drop
of funny idea and I mean it's great but
it is like it was more work than I
thought and every right everyone you
talk to with a writing gig you don't see
them doing stand-up as much because you
know sometimes they'll work you till you
know midnight you know you'd like they
work yet and it takes a lot out of it
your write and write and write and write
write and you're tired and then you get
some sleep and then you want it to be
good so sometimes I would do extra work
you know I I'm just at home until like
3:00 a.m. like getting it done so I can
you know show them in the morning and
yeah it is it is a lot of work but I
mean it's worth it they pay you good but
um it's definitely not it's not some and
but it's different jobs there's some
ready to talk to you like oh my god
might and the schedule is great they
don't they don't work us like most
writing rooms do and they have more free
time but it just depends what is it like
in there is it a lot of bouncing around
ideas or is it like you actually yes
physically writing there's there's this
table session where you're bouncing
around ideas and everybody's laughing
and it's a lot of fun and but it's not
all that a lot of it is eight hours and
in front of your computer drinking
coffee oh yeah so those are great gigs
but um and obviously I'd love to have
more I think it's I think it's fun
that's it it's like we're saying earlier
it's easier than washing dishes true
right jokes right yeah and you're like I
had to write jokes for eight hours today
it's only three grand away I can't tell
my jokes and bars and my friends as much
as used to cuz all the money I make it's
like what are you complaining about keep
perspective yeah
keep perspective every point any like
weird about bombing it's like don't take
it personally it's one show on one night
it's not the end of the world don't take
it personally
yeah gonna have a lot of bombs well dude
this has been a long time coming
yeah now in the 150s whoa and you were
number on it too my nice pour out some
water for life we can cheer some fountas
years hmm we did it oh we out here so
we're out here before we get out of here
is there anything else you want the
world to know the vote
okay I don't know this is gonna come out
after all that but yeah vote in 2020
yeah oh boy just coming out after the
midterms yeah cuz the midterms are like
okay morrow or Tuesday all right guys
well let me tell you then you're gonna
hear this after midterms look what you
did look what you know who you are why
come on really
look at this I'm look at this map right
now what are you doing come on I don't
even know who that is some group yes
some people some groups gonna be at
fault it's like I'm on his side other
people I know yeah so where can I vote
for you and follow you and support Heil
obscene and see a leb sy n a n it's hard
to say I should have changed it a long
time ago but it's too late now
sign in that's why I am look me up
Cameron without just type in Caleb Conan
you can watch me on Conan and follow me
from there and my name's spelled right
on there so my man will kill us all or
at me send me some nudes don't lie to
the DL don't send me no nudes any nudes
after Conan I got one by axe I don't
think it was meant for me I didn't
understand the caption I think she
accidentally sent it to everybody on her
phone instead of the person shooting Oh
caption didn't make any sense it looked
like it was in response I think she was
sexting with someone in accidentally did
it but uh Oh still got to see it you
still got it though my man I forgot
Caleb signing thanks beyond hot breath
God send me that will post it I think
that's illegal a hot breath everybody up
breath that's fine
sorry for spilling
[Music]